i don't want to take a shot at pilots
anywhere else in the world but
adventure means different things to
different people
i think the role of the artist is to try
and tell the story that lights your fire
and if you can do that then people are
going to pick up on that energy because
you can't help contain it
when coors light introduced me to jessa
and she wanted to paint something in the
environment i instantly thought of
little ring mountain because there's no
way to climb it and the only way to get
here is by helicopter
i'm brad friesen i'm a helicopter pilot
on the west coast of british columbia in
canada and this is my co-pilot mr
bentley the dog he uh comes with me on
pretty much all my adventures do you
want to go on the helicopter
speak
[Music]
i fly helicopters to be able to take
people and show them my backyard
[Music]
that was sick
does that look real
[Music]
my name is jessica gilbert i am an
artist based in squamish bc i had this
dream to be able to take a big canvas
out to the back country so that i can
create an artwork and then translate
that experience later on hopefully
into a mural in squamish
when i first started painting i thought
that art and adventuring had to exist in
two silos so i would go and i would work
in the studio and then i would put that
aside and then i would go and snowboard
and explore
moving to bc allowed me to meld the two
silos together and to create just one
uniformed identity
i'm so excited to share something that i
find so incredibly impactful with the
community i'm really nervous about it i
hope i can do a good job
[Laughter]
i have
never
worked with an artist
i can say that
especially not in the backcountry not
even in the four country is that a front
country
that was good you're good once we got
the uh fuel truck out of the way it was
awesome
okay
so uh we're gonna follow the squamish
river and then this will be little ring
right there it's so cool to get and to
look at more the tops of the peaks
rather than seeing it from the valley
yeah
instead of this you'll be doing that
yeah and it's not climbable it's not
something that people can get to um
without a helicopter even cooler yeah
get us there yeah all right
and squadron traffic r44 helicopter golf
yankee whiskey plus one northbound up
the squamish river any conflicting golf
dnk whiskey
okay
thanks
that's crazy
heading northbound at 1 500 feet going
right in it oh yeah we're going right
into it
[Music]
ring and then little ring
wow
they really stand out in the range
[Music]
steli
it's incredibly humbling being up here
because you realize how small you are in
the grand scheme of things
you don't even make a blip in the radar
i wanted to see the terrain that was
around to get the best orientation and
the best composition
the problem was that everything is
stunning
i did a four or five sketches and it was
like i don't know how i'm actually gonna
choose this
every time i walked around the peak you
get another view that has something
incredible about it
that one stuck out to me because not
only is it the texture of the landscape
but it tells the story of how we arrived
here
it shows the way in which we navigated
through and also the similarity in the
landscape that we're experiencing right
here
do you mind helping me set up my studio
i like helping
wow
this is definitely the most back country
my
diesel has ever been
the technique that i use for these
creations is called a single line
the goal is that once the pen touches
down on the panel
it never comes up
the reason why i like this technique is
that it requires that you're fully
engaged in your practice and your
process the entire time you're creating
the landscape
[Music]
it's really cool
temperature's dropping
how are you feeling that you uh probably
wrap up once the sun goes down sun's
gone down i don't know well once that
disappears
what time do you think you're gonna get
up and start i'd love to be up for
sunrise
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
there's always this tension about coming
back to the painting the next day after
you leave it the night before about
what does it actually look like is it
capturing that moment
what i want to capture is really just
how it feels to spend time outside and
feel the landscape and feel connected to
it
hopefully i don't screw it up
i hope that the painting that i create
can really showcase and celebrate what
it feels like to be up here because it's
it's incredible
just watching jessa telling the story of
where we are
what she's doing here is going to
translate incredibly well to the final
mural i think it's going to have a lot
of meaning for a lot of people
i hope to do this again i
i'm so
i'm filled
it's amazing
[Music]
this is a beast
the larger the wall the bigger the risk
and
the bigger impact it can potentially
make
i want to make sure that i'm giving the
community something that they could be
proud of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tomorrow morning early
uh
have some helpers coming
i'm still nervous about
how i'm going to tell people what i need
and that i don't totally blow it because
i got a lot of work to do
[Music]
this is starting to look really good
guys
we're almost here
is this it
you ready jump
hi how's it going
how are you good
this is it this is it yeah we're taking
away day two so i don't remember palm
trees on top of a mountain they're not
palm trees
they're ferns brad
today was a really productive day
i go into what i call the creative
blackout
i lose track of time i
suddenly kind of wake up a couple hours
later
[Music]
i've been thinking a lot about
what squamish means depending on what
first nation you ask it means either
bother wind or strong wind
the reason that the clouds are so
playful here is because of that wind
that energy
i want to make sure that that wind gets
visually articulated in the piece
somehow
we'll see
[Music]
i got fully in my headphones and when i
turned around there was like 50 people
here
[Music]
[Applause]
i've never had anybody
interpret a ride
she's taken sort of the essence of
flying and she's translated the whole
trip from like not only the colors but
the feeling of getting to the
environment
i want to be able to share the joy and
the gratitude i have for these places
with as many people as possible
that's what's kind of nice about the
mountains is nobody owns them
thank you so much for coming out this is
i might cry
ah this is a really big moment um
there are so many dreams that came true
with this whole project i got to make a
public piece of art in the town that i
love that i live in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers
[Applause]
this landscape changed me into a better
version of myself and i hope that the
artwork that i make and this mural can
help inspire other people to get outside
and perhaps get on their own adventures
[Music]
you